ich habe hier vor ort mit weiteren
schülern des getöteten lehrers
gesprochen denn hier über den ganzen tag
kamen hunderte franzosen am er wieder
ihre solar die solidarität und ihr
beileid mitgeteilt und diese schüler
erzählten mir dass der lehrer mit seiner
frau und wohl zwei kindern ein darunter
einem zehnjährigen sohn hier ganz in der
nähe gelebt hatte und einfach auf dem
weg nach hause war erst einmal zu fuß
zur schule gegangen und nach hause
gegangen als ihn der attentäter
auflauerte und über den attentäter gibt
es auch ein paar neue informationen er
war seit zwölf jahren in frankreich sein
vater sagte französische medien er hat
hätte von der radikalisierung nichts
mitbekommen wie sein vater
dollar im security bereich gearbeitet
haben
und die schüler erzählten mir auch noch
das fand ich interessant dass er diesen
kurs er wohl seit jahren an der schule
schon seit mehreren jahren gegeben hatte
und auch in eigentlich jedem kurs
karikaturen gezeigt hatte und zwar nicht
nur vom propheten mohammed sondern auch
die kreaturen die andere weltreligionen
aufs korn nahm
und es hatte wohl nie probleme gegeben
und das sagt mir unter anderem auch
muslimische schüler sie sagten der war
kein rassist das war einfach ein
standard kurs den alle schüler in
frankreich in der achten klasse nehmen
müssen und das war einfach teil des
unterrichts wir sind bild und wir
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier und
vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren